the question is that we reached a
tipping point in this discussion where
due process enters the discussion and
the assumption that every woman must be
believed which is what everyone was
admonished to adhere to in the early
stages of this Molly seem to be
questioned at this point well it's about
time if we have reached a tipping point
because there's nothing different about
this woman's story than many of these
other stories that we have heard from
the me2 movement you just mentioned the
standard that all women must be believed
there's this other standard where the
only thing that you have to worry about
is whether a woman feels uncomfortable
and this is the these were the judgments
that we were using to determine whether
we should take part in the me to panic
it was a panic and it was this attempt
to like come up with some kind of sexual
morality after we have thrown off all
objective sexual morality and it's
clearly not going so well I mean these
are not good ways to govern our behavior
even if it's true that men and women
should think about forming relationships
before they have sex there's a novel
idea Ben you wrote about this quite a
bit and you talked about her assertion
that he should have picked up on her
nonverbal cues I mean perhaps the
strongest nonverbal cue is you know
grabbing your jacket walking out the
door which women have been doing for
hundreds of years she didn't make that
choice here yeah I mean there were some
nonverbal cues that were given including
getting completely naked in his
apartment then performing sex acts
multiple times on him that if I were as
he's on sorry I would be thinking that's
a pretty solid nonverbal cue that you
might be into things like just just I
mean I have a hard time believing that
she really expects Aziz Ansari or that
anyone from me to expect men to be mind
reader's and this is the problem it's
one thing to say that we should believe
women about objective verifiable facts
or even just objective views of what
happened you know my hand went here and
then my head went here you know that
kind of stuff but when you're talking
about we have to believe all woman's
subjective perceptions of events that
are often very messy that are very
confusing that are very chaotic and in
which the feelings conflict in one
person forget about both people that can
flick for a woman I mean this woman was
enthusiastic at the beginning of the
date by the next morning she was talking
about how terrible it was you know is it
the job of men to now decide when women
are capable of consent I thought the
entire purpose of the feminist movement
was to say that women are supposed to be
the mistresses of their own consent that
it's not up to a man to say listen I
don't think it's possible for you to
give consent right now I don't think
this sex is in your best interest and I
don't think that we ought to be doing
this that would be mansplaining to the
woman presumably so I guess men are
caught between the rock and the hard
place of if we say no and the woman
actually is giving nonverbal cues that
say yes then we're mansplaining but if
she's gonna nonverbal cues that we think
say yes but she thinks say no then I
guess we're guilty of what sexual
assault or sexual abuse I hear you I
don't wanna let you guys go without
playing this SOT this is a totally
different story this is about the US
Olympic team and other women who were
trained by Larry Nasser who was a
trainer he has now been convicted on
seven counts of sexual assault and now
the victims are telling their side of
the story watch this I want the
nightmares of you coming into my room to
go away I want to be able to go out in
public without seeing someone that looks
like you and get so afraid that I have
to suddenly leave little girls don't see
a little forever they grow into strong
women that return to destroy your world
now there are a number of very
well-known gymnasts and all of these
young women who you see here who were
abused by the person who was supposed to
be there their trainer the person who
was looking out for them he gave them
what he called the treatment the special
treatment and they were terrified as you
can tell mckayla maroney the famous US
team gymnast
settled with the US gymnastics
Association and as part of that
settlement she's not allowed to speak
out at this or she'll be fined $100,000
in in doing so Ben your thoughts and
then we go to my I mean I'll put up some
money right now and we should start a
fund to make sure that she can speak out
however often she wants on this
particular topic I mean if me to is to
stand for anything it's to stand for the
idea that the entire culture men women
everybody look at instances of actual
sexual assault and not only condemn them
but want to make women free to talk
about them more openly this man this man
is beneath contempt and it is just
disgusting to hear what he put these
women through and how many
these young girls went through this it's
just appalling that there aren't more
people that were aware of what was going
on until this year having said that one
of the few things that victims can get
sometimes are settlements where they get
some financial compensation for the
horrors that they have gone through and
it's very noble to question
non-disclosure agreements for how they
silence victims but also we have to be
careful that we don't take away one of
the few things that sometimes victims
can get out of a very horrible situation
and if you attack non-disclosure
agreements that can actually make it
hard for women to get justice in the
future - it's a difficult situation of
child abuse ought to be able to speak
her mind and I think chrissy teigen and
others and ben shapiro have volunteered
to pay that hundred thousand dollar
fines so that she can speak out thank
you very much to both of you great to
see both tonight